solo thank you for the introduction so
my name is Andreas it was supposed that
the FD talk together was a colleague
that have to tour de talk together was a
colleague Michael he's not here actually
and so I will give the talk alone and
that means that I will leave out some
while we detailed content at the end i'm
working at the German Aerospace Center
in the simulation and software
technology division so I'm working in
the software writing software my
personal background I have a degree in
mathematics industrial mathematics and
i'm working at the Aerospace Center
since 1989 and what I'm talking about
this is basically space debris and the
software that we are developing for like
catalogue gang and analyzing space
debris data but who are we is a German
Aerospace Center I think most of you are
here from the US and don't know the deal
are the German Aerospace era but I think
most of you know NASA and if you know
another I mean we have more or less the
same but a little bit smaller I think we
have 8,000 people and another has seen
more than 30,000 people but the future
of research and refutes of working are
more or less the same so actually the
guy over there is my selfies my former
boss he was in space one year we would
we take six months on the Russian space
station and six months on the ISS and
he's a really cool guy this very nice
and as his head I'm working in the
simulation software technology division
and view to research and development in
the field of software this was a system
software engineering and
high-performance computing and where the
next sex section is a bit critical
because I'm not an aerospace engineer or
something and I'm a mathematician at
them trying to talk about space table
so what's basically the first thing that
we have to talk about this is the space
itself I mean this thing I know you know
this thing this is TOS we are living
there and most of our life is happening
on the surface surface but another part
of our life is happening in two areas
around the earth so there's likely lower
orbit 300 kilometres after two thousand
kilometers out of satellites and other
stuff is flying around her and the
geostationary orbit which is around 36
thousand kilometres most of sea
communication satellites are located in
the geostationary orbit so a lot of
space flight is going on targeting these
orbits work launches and satellite the
space station of course satellites left
for Earth Observation communication
telescopes and so on so counting users
see the capital scope of NASA which
tries to tool to find the Second Earth
or something and that since they found a
couple of interesting places they have
to go but well took takes too long to go
there actually but wait a lot of time in
the future so if the space travel is not
not very odd like we do base traveling
50 years or so and our mankind has has
launched about 5,000 rockets it's it's
not really is not not really precise we
don't know really how much lockers did
the Russians actually start or the
Chinese and so on but around 5,000
rockets we have placed about around
6,000 satellites in orbit and 1,000 of
them are actually currently active that
you're using for communication does our
stuff and espionage and so on and
there's also a lot of space debris
HD GUI is our space based or something
at that is defunct objects in space
maybe satellites that are no longer used
or rocket stages fragments from
explosions and collisions who his
objects like they were actually
astronauts who lost where tools after
repairing things slack of salt few
orchids and while other sources run over
death and the number of space to be
objects in space is increasing this is a
number this is judy says enormous from
1985 to talk 2012 and you can see it's
increasing especially at the ante are
too steep steps and this is special
events the first is in general two
thousand seven of us and Chinese
satellite that was hit by a rock by a
Chinese rocket they try to destroy their
own satellites as for some kind of let's
say military expert military experiment
and this increases the number of space
debris objects from around 4,000 to
seven eight thousand objects and another
incident was the collision an unplanned
collision of two satellites original
code this is sinking Canadian
communication satellite and cosmos or
Russian satellite they collided and
decides to more than two thousand
additional space debris objects in space
so one collision in space needs to very
very huge increase in space debris
object oops soon
as you can see like the impact of this
whiskey pictures of these two incidents
respectively of see Chinese satellite
just one month after the of tizzy where
this integration and the spatially of t2
collided satellites just 50 minutes
after the collision it's a lot of stuff
flying around after these incidents and
we have like catalogs and databases for
for storing on information about space
debris data develop cowan catalogs have
about 16,000 objects from a size larger
than well larger than 30 centimeter so
but actually in space they are smaller
objects like they are at least about
30,000 objects which are larger than 10
to 10 centimeters and say I like 750
thousand objects larger than 1
centimeter these small objects and there
are 150 million objects which are larger
than 1 millimeter and probably many many
more objects smaller than 1 millimeter
what what is it what is the what is the
impact of of these objects why why we
have to deal with space debris is
important or not so in the laboratory
you can make an experiment you can shoot
with a small one centimeter aluminum
sphere into an aluminum block which s
what's 10 centimeter J can see the
impact of this and you can imagine what
happens if such a small sphere hits and
like the International International
Space Station's or other while important
things and and real impact in spaces
this is some solar panel open satellite
which
she was hit by an space debris object
and I think we don't know the exact size
of this place to be but this causes
causes the damage and also this base
station was hit by a couple of objects
in the in the previous years but not
very large objects I'm coming with that
and the distribution and in different
attitudes from us a very different so
this is from 12 kilometers to talk two
thousand kilometers and you can see well
the interesting spaces are like about
400 kilometers of sweaty ISS lifts there
are not too many specific objects the
little bit highest like satellites like
a terrace artists as one of our radar
satellites and the most of satellites
are in the region seven and two to eight
hundred kilometers and also this is
naturally the region where are where the
most space to be objective because they
are previously the most the most
satellites near widest Weiss is
important to do is specifically but we
want to predict collisions of course for
this patient station or the mental
mental space flight it's important to
predict from a probable collusion and we
have for the space station just happens
every couple of months or weeks actually
this this was two weeks ago to Liza 16th
well the the crew of the ISS has to
leave the ISS and they went to the
Russian Soyuz module because there
wasn't space impractical crossing the
value of the ISS and well actually I
don't know they wear a tee throws a
couple of hours and then they went back
to the ISS bekasi to pay Spacely
particle when term don't hit the ISIS
and yeah actually Justin are sitting in
the back a couple of minutes ago I found
this news message from two from this
morning like five or six hours ago there
was another space to be particle
crossing the veil of the ISS and Saudi
the Russian commander like the mating
maneuver to like I don't know actually
what they did they can actually fly
higher or lower [ __ ] ISS to avoid to
avoid hitting the geese basically
particle and as you can see this this
the things happen like every every
second week or so and so it's important
that we have a good database which also
basically particles to to plan these
this maneuvers for the forum and space
right what so important thing is to like
detect space to be actually this can be
done with basically three methods you
can use radar or you can optical
telescopes or you can let Google use
lasers we are to deal I use radar and
optical telescopes for example County we
are working on monitoring Network
Scott's market which optical telescopes
it consists of like six telescopes this
rule over the world this which which
operates like a vertical and they have
optimized schedules for the telescope
since the locations are like this and
then also in southern hemisphere so they
can cover all the space around us so and
then there's like data that we get like
images like that like this with space we
object in the middle and we have then do
like computations to do the object
correlation to get
um attracts than T the orbit of these
basically p particles so this is the
part where I'm not going into details
but I'm talking now about is a software
for like managing the the over our
database infrastructure on for aunty
computation of orbits and so on it's
called peccati its backbone catalogue of
rationalization and debris information
it's there by database this it should be
complete it amin it should contain also
important this phase three objects with
high accuracy from sensors and from as
operational data and from other like sir
party data sources the signs that we are
doing is software's hard to build this
kind of disabled atta base and well
actually the space engineers are working
on on the computations for object
correlation orbit determination
propagation object identification to
identify what kind of particle is it
actually and for like detection of
maneuvers or further fragmentation of
space debris particles I mean but what
happens from time to time is that it to
space three particles collide and split
into many more like particles that we
have to hopefully automatically find out
what efforts happening and and dejected
so and the bacardi system must have
mission support it must be used to
provide orbit information collision
detected action we enter your prediction
of particles and this short do I in real
time in space operation center I think
this is the one that we run in
in Munich in Germany is off everyone at
at the end of this year the over your
overview of the system is lied SST very
detailed I've got system over you with
all the parts that that are important
for for the different computational
predictions a more simplified view is
this we have sensor network with a
particular radar nasal sensors we have T
park aeri system is actually databases
using the face and processes and in the
yes well in the blood of the aerospace
engineer processes are not really
processes on the computer but that our
algorithm said want compute something
like an orbit or on prediction arm of in
collision or something like that it's a
processes and we have SD sensor
scheduler and below that control C
telescopes we have corrections to as a
user to user groups and we have
additional external information and the
internal node T processors are very well
there are a lot of things for object
proper orbit propagation orbit a
termination and so on and so on and I'm
not going into detail here and another
example is we have external data sources
this is this is one with which you can
actually try out space tractor dork you
can go there we get stuff for an account
and get information about the orbit
information about you about the about
mouse most of the satellites and other
objects at iron space in this screenshot
SST steer
yeah it's the ISS International Space
Station it has the dige 255 44 and bill
at the bottom you can see this is
working the bottom we can see the orbit
information of till last orbit of the
ISS at the last trip around two years of
the ISS from made this winter this
morning is actually data from this
morning sensi space system components of
the ducati system i actually like a
database caching processing importing
data and we built a middle way I wanted
you call the middle who a Skynet I'm
explained that in a minute and the
processing is done is two ways where the
colleagues geospace injuries have like
two kinds of processors one half of that
is fortunate for oncology other half
newer ones are actually Python code and
also we have things like security and
traceability was a system and the basic
middlewares called Skynet the name is
not actually very good but it has some
kind of meaning network for surveillance
of the sky so this might check the name
might might change in the future
actually and we didn't do a guess
they're like names to get up on so for
that because we are thinking about other
names County but as this is only the
Middle where is hidden by actually by
the users that are using the system yeah
the objectors of the middle base using
the suit centralized mesh message queues
for exchanging data with tunze different
parts of system the middle right build
scalable self-organized network of
processes and other stuff from databases
with minimal network overhead this is
important and it must be platform
independent so the production using
these spatial relation center what is on
Linux but see with development is mostly
in windows on mac OS
and we want to have provenance recording
and the technology decisions that we
make for the first version currently is
we we are basing it we based it on
zeromq for the central decentralized
network infrastructure and felicity we
use protocol buffers for civil a
civilization of data and SQL agony for
different database mapping and
especially 0nq button protocol buffers
are really available on unlike many
platforms and from any programming
languages and different modules of
skynet are like network maloom the data
model module the module posters for
processes and the record model module
for provenance from the network module
as his head is based on 0 and Q I know
if you haven't tried to you and Q first
things that's a really cool library for
a basic electrical library for messaging
very few over it it's not based on a
central broker such as other like
messaging rivals but you can configure
than the Dre that it has a burger it's
really nice and to him flexible it's
multi-platform multi-language fast and
small and actually can realize many
correction patterns it's configurable
this enlightened configuration language
well actually these patterns are not
from juba Skylit systems is as of trust
examples and Skynet network our network
layer actually is based on CL on cue we
have to fine-tune like an device as an
abstract endpoint and zeromq we just
defined why as easy omq configuration
language set ECF 0q device configuration
fire we do like automatically connect
devices to each other if steph it will
support compression of light a cloud
data
a civilization via protocol buffers and
seeing that we want to incorporate next
year is encryption and signing of the
layer and the network could look like
that so we have different devices like a
broker or two brokers and a couple of
worker nodes that do actually do
computations and maybe database nodes
and so on and the layout of the graph
changes from from task to task actually
for the serialization as a set we use
protocol buffers this is also a nice
technology at just very suited for for
applications way of high performance
constraints is specified by Google
actually open source it's similar to
like what people are doing with XML for
serializing structure data efficient
extensible and you have to give define
like your your data structure in an
interface definition language IEA and in
our model model module of sky and reuse
protocol buffer or models or data models
are defined as protocol buffer messages
we provide like basic data types for
vectors and orbital data and so on
interfaces for caching we do mapping to
database to actual database with SQL q
me where we add like certain annotations
to the protocol buffer messages we have
special adviser slide for database
creation so the model definition in this
kind it is is in a way that we are
mapping photo buffer protocol buffers to
a database table and we add like some
kind of annotations to the to the
protocol buffers this is in this line
here the system
portable laser system for the Gulf alpha
interface definition file see we import
like things for the database collection
and then lose you too Marshall G for
example in a definition of a vector this
naturally very simple so the Skynet
model is actually very simple we have a
network message that we can send around
which contains over here in header and
different blocks of well different tons
of data the header contains the
destination Vsauce listen Z network and
the different blocks can contain data
from different databases or four
different databases or command so as I
see things and the model definition can
be rather complicated the motor
definition for orbital parameters on
orbitz is like I don't know three or
four pages on the screen as you can see
ya you can try to read us and we have
many many models for other for other
things that we have to compute and to
actually go from an protocol buffer
definition to an extra database this
this is really easy you can just tweet
the model definition and like create
database structure and a little finesse
trail if just for an example because the
most easiest thing my picture support
our databases that s where I can be
actually supports and create a database
Terry Ranson you can work on the
database on and the distributed system
and the data access is also very simple
we can access the data where we can do
regular Travis on the databases or we
have like in database extension module
defined in in Skynet for for easy access
to
you through the data for example to get
the orbital information for your eyes s
you just may can just make an coil you C
code I deepali is actually in practice
this is very simple and the engineers
are actually very pleased of this
solution so the next part of this kind
of the sea process layer this is an
extraction let s play obstruction air
for you for the processes as a set
fortran code or Python codes so actually
is some of them are actually see codes
mmm the integration is well it's in
classical we can do like sub processes
with ILY live wire files or disk i/o
land n pipes or we can wrap Python or
photon Python and we can wrap photon OC
with Python to importers add it as a
Python code or you can write by a pure
python modules and using that we also
use device and support live Malti to
multiple processes where we put one
process on a single coil single CPU I'm
not going into detail on the set so the
last thing the last part of the opti
Skynet system is province recording
problems is some kind of metadata this
describes the the process this leads to
it leads to some piece of data actually
so as you can see President provinces
defined as a rock a record just
describes or people institutions
entities activities that that I involved
in producing a piece of data or saying
is the definition and you can see in the
general picture VF
entities for exam provides or activities
like processes or tools of software or
agents for example of the humans as our
steering computation and then we define
the process that we have the sub kind of
a provenance model and we can store
actually if you're running your process
you can store information about your
learning process in this data model and
what we're doing this is like a standard
from the wii w3c congoleum from the
semantic gap field and what we are doing
in in Skynet is a provenance accordingly
to record all activities during one time
this we can support my temper problem
stores provenance stores actually are
neo4j graph databases because the
provenance model itself is a graphic
direct ex actly graph and he's naturally
used in a graph database for that and
providence is important for traceability
and prove ability of all data that we
have in this system so for backtracking
of each produce data product and for
reproducibility of all products and all
the data that we have generated so where
we will actually very nice technology so
coming to an end what is the current
state on Jake Allen Rock currently
working on new graphical user interface
recognize that you haven't seen any
graphical user interface VF true
versions of web web user interface based
on django and we're working on desktop
version pipe based on cutie and pike
Yuki and we are currently working on the
only workflow execution and distributed
Network and organization or topics at
work are you working on this without
your workflows and the salty reserved up
web user interface we county provide
operation reversion to end of this year
within our own organization and we
beside that we are working on an
extended version with which there's some
improved security and signing on and so
on for especially for deed for the
german army for the Bundeswehr which
should be working there in 2017 or so
and we also like or actually started
working and using Skynet and other
fields for example VF no started a
project where we have to acquire data
from a rocket motor which is in rocket
that actually starts and we have take
why are the data during the start and
then analyze the data so that the
engineers can well watch and see what
happens during young and launched
rockets and this will also by the
activity have started and for that
actually weird well for a clear deadline
this is it's nice and sofa project the
rocket starts actually in my 2018 and in
December 2017 we have to provide a
software truly colleagues who who
prepares a rocket and it must then well
just work and that's it what I wanted to
say thank you if you have questions you
can ask me know or later otherwise we
can go to lunch yeah yeah the nature is
very important problem is
number of collisions at humanik debris
in orbit increase is not in linear which
means that the items in your database
yeah we'll have to increase nine here
yes is how do you keep the database from
hitting its capacity under those
circumstances it is it easy to extend
well actually we can I mean we County we
replan vez like a couple of millions of
objects which is really not too much in
the feet of database technology and I
think it's Hannibal and what we're
trying to do there is to try to trade 08
multiple databases we just not use
someone singer database but multiple
databases we can just it another late
again yeah yeah and remote the biggest
problem instantly processing the
processing power oh there's wide range
of timelines for processing like four
minutes to two weeks or even months so
in some cases like the incident like two
weeks ago we have there was some time
out for about three or four weeks so a
couple of weeks before that we know that
the essence basically object and the key
colleagues in space can plan their work
and then relax move to the so you skype
own spaceship and wait and drink coffee
and so on and as I incidents we have
maybe only now also so but actually the
system is planted as observes the sky
every time and do computations all the
time around and so we can predict it
means the different cases if the faces
be objects split into multiple objects
and we cannot really predict us for all
cases and we have to observe the sky and
determine if an object is not present
anymore intimus probably they are more a
couple of Morrowind that's the reason
why we have to like to do processing all
the time without any end and hopefully
we can predict incidence way ahead of
when [ __ ] happens okay
okay so yeah oh yeah
oh you mean from if you are you from the
user perspective is it will be
interactive yeah that's a retinal
requirement especially by the army yeah
okay thanks lunch